[Music]
what happened by your forward becky
search continues for four inmates who
escaped federal custody this morning
authorities say the men are armed and
extremely dangerous
come on boy let's go swimming oh can you
wait a second what is she doing here
you let her walk all over you she's 13.
jeff this gentleman lost his dog okay
well why don't you give us your number a
dog is a rottweiler
purebred what does the germans call them
violent
that's why you never let them mate with
other breeds you get the worst of both
okay i think it's time for you to go
stay calm i'm looking for a key
it has this symbol engraved on it you
seen it
no oh that leaves little becky where's
becky
wait wait he's gonna hold your dad still
while i hurt him
i'm not gonna let them get away with
this
[Music]
she was horny
[Music]
what was the point of all of this for a
key it's worth much more than that
okay you're clearly a special girl i
don't want to have to hurt you
but i do want to hurt you real bad
[Music]
you